hello and welcome it's September 18th
2023 and it's active guest stream 57.1
with Andy Keller we're going to be
talking about natural neural structure
for artificial intelligence there will
be a presentation followed by a
discussion so if you're watching live
please feel free to write questions in
the live chat otherwise thank you Andy
for this really looking forward to it
and to you for the presentation
yeah thanks so much uh thanks for having
me I'm super excited to be able to
present this stuff with the active
reference group I'm a fan and very
interested so hopefully uh yeah get to
have a good discussion and see what you
guys think about it
um so my name is Andy I'm finishing up
my PhD supervised by maxwelling at the
University of Amsterdam
um I'm starting a postdoc Harvard after
this so I'll start out I'm just talking
about the goal of my work in general is
to try to bring modern artificial
intelligence closer to more human-like
generalization and so what we mean by
this is maybe some sort of structure
generalization
um or maybe more familiar to the active
infants committee like a structured
World model which we believe that humans
have and the way that we propose to do
this is by integrating natural neural
structure into artificial intelligence
so first let's define what we mean by
structure generalization
so I think it's fairly uncontroversial
to say that modern machine learning
generalizes Beyond its training set in
the traditional sense so for example
even the earliest artificial neural
networks multi-layer perceptrons could
be trained on data sets of images like
this and Achieve high accuracy then when
they're presented with a held out test
set of images that they've never seen
before they can still classify them
relatively easily with the same level of
accuracy and this is what we typically
call generalization however even fairly
early on it was noticed that these
systems really struggle with small
shifts or deformations apply to the
images for example if
so you think why is this surprising and
I argue it's really due to our innate
ability to perform this type of
structure generalization that this
example is a failure of so uh for
example this shift is nearly
imperceptible to us and we handle it
automatically whereas in the system it's
very clearly a major problem so in words
we can say that structure generalization
is a generalization to some symmetry
transformations of the input or in this
case the Symmetry transformation is a
small shift that leaves the digit class
unchanged
so the obvious question then is what
precisely do we mean by this natural
structure and why do we think that this
would help us with these settings
so first let's talk about what we mean
by natural neural structure
um one way to talk about structure or or
any type of bias in a system is an
inductive bias and so an inductive bias
can Loosely be defined as an appriore
restriction of a set of realizable
hypotheses when you're doing model
selection more colloquially we can call
this something like before seeing any
data it's a restriction of what and how
you can learn so very broadly this can
include anything from model class to
optimization procedures or even hyper
parameters and in some sense they really
Define what is
what is possible to learn and it defines
generalization in that
you actually can't generalize Beyond a
training set without having some
inductifying solution this is explained
more thoroughly in this paper by David
Wolford so what we mean by natural
inductive biases then is biases that
stem from the restrictions and
limitations that are faced by natural
systems uh by the nature of having to
live in the real world for example the
brain has many efficiency constraints
and physical constraints by nature of
its construction uh and following this
logic then these constraints are really
playing some role in our generalization
abilities which currently exceed modern
artificial intelligence as we'll go into
next so in this talk I'll be focusing
specifically on two types of structure
which my work has studied these are
topographic organization and
spatiotemporal Dynamics and before I go
into my work I'll give a short example
for why I believe that natural structure
may be useful to achieve the structure
generalization that I was talking about
before
so the first example comes from uh
hukushima's neocognitive front
architecture from the 1980s which was
actually which was actually built to
directly address the problem of
robustness to these small shifts and
deformations so in the paperwork he
writes about inspiration from pupil and
weasel's measurements of hierarchy and
pooling in order to achieve robustness
to these distortions and so if you look
at the figure if he writes U sub S1 U
sub C1 and these stand for simple and
complex cells and so this is a fairly
radical Approach at the time but it
really served to improve robustness and
shifts that we're plaguing these early
artificial neural networks and over time
these ideas were simplified and
abstracted and obviously yielded the
convolutional neural networks so we know
today which ultimately drove the success
of the deep learning Revolution so this
is really an example of a natural
inductive bias which achieved structure
generalization so for our research it's
really utmost interest to try and
understand what makes these models work
so well
um and see if this principle can
potentially be generalized to cover more
abstract more abstract Transformations
and symmetries
so what makes a convolution achieve this
structure generalization
intuitively you can see this is done by
applying the same filter at or or
feature extractor at various spatial
locations so here we see a single
convolutional filter being applied at
all locations of an image this means
that no matter where your input is
whether it's kind of in the middle of
the image or on the right you'll have
the exact same features with one
exception they'll be equivalently
shifted
so mathematically this type of a mapping
is called a homomorphism it preserves
the algebraic structure of the input
space and the output space in this case
it's with respect to translation and at
a simple a simple level something like
that will be important to remember for
the rest of this talk is that we can
verify homomorphisms of our feature
extractor if we can see that there's
this community commutation with the
Transformations commutative diagram and
so we can write this also algebraically
by showing that the feature extractor f
commutes with the transformation
operator t
and basically what we want is there to
be no difference between first
extracting the features and then
performing the transformation or
performing the transformation and then
extracting the features so the challenge
is to date is
we don't really know how to construct
homomorphisms with respect to more
complex Transformations that we see in
the real world for example our brain is
able to handle changes in lighting and
season naturally
um so here we see Lighting on a person's
face or the change of seasons we can
tell it's the same face or the the same
road but we don't know how to build
models which respect these
Transformations and so it makes us hard
to build systems which handle them in a
robust and predictable way
to give an even more abstract example of
what I mean by this and the potential
negative repercussions of models which
don't handle symmetry Transformations
consider modern text to image generation
programs so in this example I asked
Dolly to to generate a image of a teddy
bear on the moon and it does this
incredibly well right probably better
than I could it has texture fur uh
incredibly detailed however if I ask you
to do something which I see is
conceptually simpler such as draw a blue
cube on top of a Red Cube it fails to do
this and to me this seems unintuitive
since the second task seems
significantly easier but what I'm
arguing is that the reason that this is
surprising is precisely the same reason
that the amnest translation example was
surprising there is this symmetry
transformation Happening Here namely the
transformation between these complex
objects of a teddy bear and the moon and
these simple objects of Cubes which we
intuitively expect the network to be
able to handle and respect and we see
that it doesn't so just like how
fukushima's work showed that these
natural structure of hierarchy and
pooling of our visual system are
effective for making generalizations to
small Transformations I argue that
potentially higher level structure may
be necessary to fix these abstract
generalization problems
and so the question then that I'm
studying and that I'm asking is what
might this structure be and how do we
implement this in a artificial neural
network architecture that can actually
be used for performing computation
so to begin to answer that I'll jump
into my first line of work on
topographic organization
so topographic organization is observed
widely throughout the brain from primary
visual cortex Sapphire level areas and
it can very Loosely be described as this
property that neurons which are close to
one another tend to respond to similar
things for example on the left we show
the color-coded preference of each
neuron in the primary digital cortex as
a response to oriented lines and we see
this smoothly varying set of
selectivities another type of
organization is known as retina topic
organization where nearby neurons in the
visual cortex tend to respond to nearby
receptive fields
however this organization isn't limited
to these low-level features extends some
more complex features such as those
present in faces or objects or places
and this relates to the so-called
functionally specific areas of the brain
such as the fusiform face area FFA and
the parakhippocampal face area PPA
so in this work the main idea again is
that perhaps this topographic
organization in some sense which is
intimately related to the convolution
operation and fukushima's architecture
we can maybe generalize the benefits of
this to more abstract transformations in
other words learn how to build more
complex homomorphisms that we can't do
you know we can't do analytically right
now
so just to show that we're not
completely insane with this idea uh
there is some prior work in this domain
from people such as uh Conan Galaxy
Barden in the early 90s and and 2000s
and they studied how topographic
organization may be useful for learning
in variances mostly in linear models so
the question for us when we entered the
space is what is the most scalable
abstract mechanism that can be leveraged
from these approaches which we can
integrate into modern deep neural
network architectures and ultimately we
settled on a generative modeling
approach which I think might be
interesting to the people in this
community
um which then allows us to relate it
more closely to topographic independent
component analysis with the basic idea
being that we can learn a topographic
feature Space by imposing a topographic
prior distribution over our latent
variables
so just to give a brief background I
assume most people are already familiar
with this
um but the kind of General assumption is
that the brain is a generative model and
this idea in some sense can be
attributed to helmholts from the 19th
century uh where he said that what we
see is the solution to a computational
problem our brains compute the most
likely causes from Photon absorptions
within our eyes and so that's an example
if I show you this image you immediately
recognize it as a globe with some
curvature however it could just as
equally be a disc with a distorted
perspective on that so this is how we
get optical illusions or our images so
like this one your brain infers that
there is a cube here because of the
structure but really it's just a flat
piece of paper
so you can think of this generative
model aspect that's kind of like an
inverse Graphics program
in the program the abstract properties
of the sphere are known the position the
size the lighting and these are used to
project the sphere to create the 2D
image that is rendered so in effect what
Humboldt's and others are saying is that
as a generative model the brain is
actually trying to invert this
generative process and doing inference
and infer the underlying causes of our
Sensations
so the reason I'm kind of belaboring
this point is that there's a lot of
talking generative models today
um and I'm not necessarily just talking
about generating images or pretty
pictures
um I really want to mean
a framework for unsupervised learning
so then to get a little bit more into
the details what do I mean by a
topographic prior so generative models
are typically described as a joint
distribution over observations X and
latent variables which we'll call Z uh
and this is typically factorized or one
way that this is done is factorized in
terms of a prior P of Z and this true
generative model conditional generative
model P of x given Z and so one way that
we can think about this is that the
prior can be seen to encode relative
penalties for each type of code that is
produced when we invert our generative
model this is called Computing the
posterior P of Z given X
and so to develop a topographic latent
space we want to introduce some sort of
a topographic prior which has been or
which this topographic ICA work showed
is equivalent to something like a group
sparsity penalty
so people might be familiar with typical
sparsity penalties from Independent
Learning analysis you want your
activations to be sparse meaning many of
them are zero wow and so that could look
something like this you have a bunch of
blue squares that are active but most of
them are not active but specifically
with the group's Varsity penalty we want
these priors to assign lower probability
to these distributed sparse activations
and higher probability to these grouped
densely packed representations you can
also think of this like a higher penalty
when things are spread out a lower
penalty when things are closer together
so again uh this can be written
abstractly like this but I want to make
theory that these neurons each one of
these squares here represents kind of a
neuron in our model and they're
organized in this 2D grid so when we're
talking about grouping we really mean
grouping in that 2D topology
so one thing that's really interesting
and kind of important is that these
priors don't just give us topographic
organization but they've also been noted
by people like or studied by people like
erosi Marcelli and Bruno also to
actually fit the statistics of natural
data better
specifically natural images
they've shown that using this type of a
prior you actually get a sparser set of
activations meaning that the prior fits
the true generative process a little bit
better and as we're aware the brain has
a high degree of sparsity and this is
believed to be very relevant for
efficiency
so to get a little bit more into the
details to implement this type of a
group sparse prior we use a hierarchical
generative model and this is uh
basically introduced by some of the
topographic ICA work
um the idea is that you have a higher
level latent variable U which
simultaneously regulates the variance of
multiple lower level variables T and
this is how we get group sparsity
then to get topographic organization you
can have multiple of these latent
variables used slightly overlapping with
their fields of influence so their their
neighborhoods we can call them
and this will give you this smooth
correlation structure your act you're
after so get the intuition for this you
see that this variable T over down on
the bottom here is not getting any input
from this U on the top but it is sharing
a u variable with this T in the middle
so it's like they're sharing variants
they're sharing some components with
their neighbors but not all components
and that's really due to this local
connectivity of these higher level
variables you
so to keep it simple about how we use a
generative model let's go back to a
single U variable and the challenge in
this type of an architecture which made
it difficult for for many years is how
do you infer the approximate posterior
over these intermediate variables in
this hierarchical architecture and this
is not super straightforward so prior
Works have used heuristics developed for
linear models and in our work we found
that this really didn't extend to Modern
neural network architectures so really
our Insight is to leverage a
factorization a specific
re-parametrization of this distribution
and so this parameterization
specifically is achieved by defining the
priority what's known as a gaussian
scale mixture meaning that our
conditional distribution of T given U is
actually a normal distribution where the
the variance is defined by this variable
U and for certain choices of U this
distribution is indeed sparse and
encompasses a range of distributions
such as laplossians a suit and T
distributions one way of defining it is
a gaussian scale mixture emits a
particular reframe re-parameterization
in terms of independent gaussian random
variables Z and U so specifically then
we we see that this T variable which was
originally fairly complex is actually
just a product of a bunch of gaussian
random variables which now know how to
work with much more efficiently uh in in
generative models specifically what
we're going to do is so that we can
actually get approximate posteriors for
U and Z separately and then do a
deterministic combination of them in
order to compute our topographic
variable T and this is much easier to do
so without going into too many details
the method that we decided to use is
what's known as a variational
autoencoder which leverages techniques
from variational inference to derive a
lower bound on the likelihood allowing
us to parametrize these approximate
posteriors with powerful non-linear deep
neural networks and optimize them with
gradient descent this is going to be
familiar to the active inference
Community but really what we've done is
instead of having a single encoder in
decoder as a typical baes we now have
two encoders one for you and one for Z
separately and then we combine them in
this deterministic manner to construct
our topographic T variable if you see
that this is a is actually the
construction of a student's T
distribution from gaussians
and then we can plug this we do this
before decoding and uh and then maximize
the likelihood of the data altogether so
this is the elbow the evidence lower
bound abound on the likelihood of the
data and is actually very similar to the
variational free energy that is used in
active entrance community
so with with these details out of the
way what's really interesting is what
happens when we train this generative
model which has relatively simple group
sparsity penalty in its latent space and
we want to look at kind of what it's
learning in terms of its organization of
Futures and first we start with the
simplest possible data set we have a
black background with white squares at
random XY locations and if we train our
autoencoder with this group sparsity
penalty on it and then we look at the
weight vectors of our decoder which
we're plotting in blue here again
organized on this 2D grid we see that
indeed they learn to be organized
according to spatial location so this
can be seen as similar to convolutional
receptive fields or the receptive field
of each neuron is really given by the
the kind of inputs at its location
and this makes sense intuitively from
the group's sparsity perspective since
for any given region to highlight like
in yellow here the filters in a given
group are much more highly correlated
they have these overlapping receptive
Fields than other random locations so
essentially we see that our model is
learning to Cluster activity activities
together
uh in sort of a simulated vertical sheet
according to the correlations in the
data set so instead of in convolution
where you're actually doing weight tying
and you're manually specifying I want to
copy this weight everywhere you can
maybe think of this as like approximate
wait time
and really we're learning this from the
correlation structure of the data set
itself and just to give a little bit
more of a biological inspiration for
this and we know that retinotopia is
present in the brain this is an example
of retinotopia in the visual cortex and
you can see if you show the macaque an
image like this it gets projected into
this uh
topology preserving space actually on
the surface of the cortex
so the idea is that topographic
organization and even learn topographic
organization is preserving the input
correlations of our data sets uh and and
potentially uh this may be beneficial
for generalizing these ideas a little
bit further so like I said at the
beginning uh it would be even better if
we could just learn something more than
just convolution maybe more complicated
equivariances so how do we do that one
thing that's clear in natural
intelligence is that we don't exist in
this world of IID frames right we exist
in a world with continuous sequences of
Transformations so maybe we can extend
our model to this setting to learn
observe Transformations this is an idea
of temporal coherence
so what would happen if we just simply
extended our previous framework over the
time Dimension right so instead of just
grouping saying we want our neurons to
be group sparse in terms of spatial
extent on the cortex we actually want
them to be group sparse over time
meaning that if one set of neurons is
active now we want that same set of
neurons to be active into the future as
well
if we look at if we kind of intuitively
think about this we see that this is
actually more encouraging invariance and
equivariance a way to understand this is
we're saying we want the same neurons to
be active constantly but the input
transformation is changing right the the
feet of this little fox are moving so if
the same neurons are coding for the same
thing over and over again but the feet
are moving those neurons are going to
learn to be invariant to the motion of
that leg of this dog for example
so instead is that oops
I went the wrong way here uh
so instead uh our Insight was that this
group starts to be could instead be
shifted with respect to time so this
would mean that sequentially shifted
sets of activations would be encouraged
to activate together and then our latent
space would really be structured with
respect to the observed Transformations
so you can see here that rather than the
same set of neurons being active at all
time steps it's really a sequentially
permuted set of neurons that we're
grouping together in this sparse way uh
and and then this allows us to model
different observations over time but
they're still connected in terms of
learning a transformation and preserving
this correlation structure of the
empathy
so if we put this together into our
topographic Bae architecture you can get
something that looks like this you see
that we have an input sequence we're
again encoding a z variable and then
multiple U variables in the denominator
here and then each one of these U
variables is shifted uh kind of like we
were showing before in order to achieve
this this shift equivariance structure
that we're looking for when we combine
these in this student T product
distribution we get a single latent
variable this is now our topographic
variable T and now that we have this
known structure in our latent space you
can think of it like a structured World
model we know how to transform this
latent space in this case it's by
permuting these activations around these
circles doing like a cyclic role a
cyclic shift we know that this is going
to correspond to our learned input
Transformations and we can verify that
by saying okay what if I continue this
input transformation the true
transformation in the data set which is
a rotation and then I compare that with
how I've done my role in my late Space
by moving my activations around in my
brain and then we decode and we see that
we get the exact same thing and so this
is demonstrating this commutility
property that I was talking about before
for verifying homomorphism
and so to measure this a little bit more
quality quantitatively uh we can measure
what's called an equivariance loss so
this is really the quantification of
this difference between our rolled
capsule activation or rolling in our
head versus watching the rolling unfold
and forward they're watching the
transformation unfold before us so we
see the topographic Bae achieves
significantly lower uh equivariance
error this bubble vae is what I was
talking about before where it's learning
invariance so it doesn't have the shift
operation and the traditional vae kind
of has no notion of organization or
temporal component so performance very
poorly in addition to this we see that
the model is a better generative model
of sequences it just gets a lower uh
lower like negative log likelihood uh on
the data set so it's it's better able to
model this data set because it has a
notion of the structure of the
transformations
uh we can test this on multiple
different transformation types and the
top row we're showing the true
transformation we pulled out these
grayed out images and then on the bottom
row we encode and then we just kind of
roll our activations around and we keep
decoding to see what the what the model
uh has learned as the current
transformation that's being observed and
we see that it can basically perfectly
reconstruct these elements of the
sequence that it's never seen before
additionally with images that are from
the test set that it's never seen before
simply because it knows what the
transformation is that it's currently
encoding it can generalize that to new
examples
so the takeaway from this part is really
topographic organization we showed that
a preserved input structure and now
we're showing it can potentially improve
efficiency and generalization as we
would hope uh
so finally something that surprised us
and I thought was potentially the most
interesting is that these these
Transformations that are learned by our
model actually generalize the
combinations of Transformations that
we're not seeing during training so for
example despite only training on color
and rotation Transformations and
isolation if the model is presented with
a combined color rotation transformation
at test time uh we we see that it's able
to completely model and complete these
Transformations perfectly through the
capsule role implying that it's learned
to factorize represent to these
different Transformations and it can
flexibly combine them at inference time
so again maybe we also don't just get
officially efficiency in generalization
we also get some basic compositionality
so let's talk about the limitations and
what we could do next uh the main
limitation is that there's a predefined
transformation that we're imposing uh in
both space and time so although we freed
ourselves from group Transformations and
specifically like uh translation or
rotation as it's currently done in the
machine learning World
um we still have uh this hard-coded
latent role in our heads for everything
we see and to make this a little bit
more flexible so hopefully we can model
a greater diversity of Transformations
um we we think maybe we can take
inspiration from more structured spatial
temporal dynamics that are observed in
the brain and so that takes us to the
the second part of this talk which is uh
spatial temporal dynamics that we're
going to try to integrate into
artificial neural networks one example
of that is traveling waves like I showed
here
so what do we mean by that uh well
here's a very recent paper where they
used a nine Tesla fmri operating at 36
millisecond resolution to image a single
slice of a rat brain under anesthesia
and what we see is this very clearly
structured spatial temporal activity and
correlations and these authors of the
paper go on to analyze this activity in
terms of the principal modes as depicted
on the right so our hypothesis is that
perhaps some sort of a correlation
structure like this may be beneficial
for structuring the representations of
our model with respect to observed
Transformations but in a much more
flexible way than simply just a cyclic
shift like we were doing before
um
and let me say that this is not just
observed in an ssi's rats uh this you
can you can see these traveling waves
happen in the Mt cortex of awake
behaving primates uh so for example on
the left here they show traveling waves
that actually uh
change How likely a primate is to see a
low contrast stimuli based on the phase
of the wave furthermore they show that
the like a high contrast stimulus on the
right uh can induce a traveling wave
activity that propagates outwards even
in primary visual cortex so these are
really ubiquitous throughout the brain
at multiple levels and it would be
interesting to study what their
implications are for uh structure
representation learning in our case or
or generally
there is prior work which has studied
these types of uh Dynamics and they
build models so on the top these are the
equations which describe a spiking
neural network which they show if you
implement time delays actually axonal
time delays between neurons you do get
these structure dynamics of traveling
waves as long as your network size is
large enough
um however as many people probably know
it's relatively challenging to train
spiking neural networks of the same size
and performance as deep neural networks
similarly on the bottom another system
which is significantly simpler but
perhaps too simple uh is a network of
coupled oscillators these are known to
exhibit synchrony and spatial temporal
Dynamics and complex patterns but uh
this is called like a phase reduce
system and doesn't quite capture the
full complexity that we're interested in
so we're looking at something that's
potentially in between these two
and what we settled on is this work in
this work is uh to parameterize a
network of couple of oscillators
slightly more flexibly than a paramoto
model so this is really
built on this couple distillatory
recurrent neural network of Constantine
rush and Nisha
um where they basically took the
equation which describes a simple
harmonic oscillator it's a second order
differential equation the acceleration
on a ball on a spring is proportional to
its displacement
uh you can add additional terms such as
damping so that the oscillations slowly
die out over time
you can drive this oscillator with an
external input to kind of counteract
this damping or to give slightly more
complexity to the Dynamics
and then furthermore if you have many of
these oscillators you can couple them
together with these coupling matrices W
uh as we demonstrate kind of in this
picture here so you can really think of
this network as a bunch of bubbles on
Springs and they're maybe connected to
each other also by Springs or elastic
bands whatever the couple distillatory
recurrent neural network of Russian
Mishra uh with these various terms and
this has been shown to be very powerful
for modeling long sequences they also
mentioned they were inspired by the
brain building this and there's a lot of
good analysis in that paper uh for
example they show that this is really
beneficial properties with respect to
Vanishing gradient problems that
typically happen in recurrent neural
networks
um but if we want to look at spatial
temporal Dynamics and this type of a
model uh it's slightly challenging
because these coupling matrices here the
W's
that connect each neural or each
oscillator is positioned to one another
these are densely connected matrices
like I've tried to depict on the left
here
so if you try to visualize the Dynamics
of this network you don't see any
spatial organization there's no
inheritance it's apology to the latent
space of this model
um so you can think of this like in our
previous example a neuron is connected
to a potentially arbitrary set of other
neurons those neurons are connected to
another arbitrary set of neurons and
you'll just get oscillatory Dynamics
certainly but kind of fluctuations that
don't make a lot of structured sense so
in our work then we thought okay how can
we convert this more to the the types of
dynamics that we're interested in this
structured propagation of activity uh
and one clear way to do that is to have
a more structured connectivity Matrix W
uh which we found is easily implemented
and efficiently implemented through a
convolution operation which you can
think of like a local a locally
connected layer so instead of having
every neuron connected every neuron
neurons are just connected to their
nearby neighbors you after training
you'll end up getting something that
looks like a smooth spatial temporal
Dynamics
so to be a little bit more clear to
train this model we take this separate
second order differential equation that
we were describing before you discretize
it into two first order equations you
can think of this as like numerically
integrating the ode we now have a
velocity and then we update
uh and and we can train this model as
something like an auto encoder or an
auto regressive model so if we take an
input we encode it to our latent space
really the input is Dr is this f of x
term which acts as the driving term so
it's like driving these oscillators from
the bottom uh and then they have their
own Dynamics which are defined by the
coupling terms these local couplings and
then at each time step we take this
latent State this wave state and we
decode to try and reconstruct the input
and be at the current time step or a
future time step
we can do some analysis of of these
models uh during training to see what
happens before training and after
training we can compute the phase and
the velocity of the Dynamics in the
latent space basically we see at the
beginning of trading there's no waves in
our model but after training after 50
epochs we see that there's a smooth
structured activity propagating
downwards uh in service of this sequence
modeling task that we're doing like
rotating objects
um so what's what's the benefit of this
I mean the whole reason I motivated this
was to say we wanted to have more
flexibly learned structure are we
actually doing that or are we just
getting pretty waves
um so what we showed in our paper is
that we really are learning some sort of
useful structure and the way we showed
that is again with something like this
commutative diagram if you take an input
and you encode it and you get a wave
state and then you propagate waves
artificially in that wave state and then
decode you can observe that it's
actually exactly the same as if you had
just by showing a bunch of different
images of different Transformations so a
lot of different uh digits different
features and we see that we get
different types of wave activity in each
case in order to model that different
transformation
if we train it on different data sets as
well we similarly see more complex
Dynamics in this case maybe not even
traveling waves or standing waves which
can be thought of as traveling waves in
opposite directions so we see if we're
modeling these orbital Dynamics we get
these kind of smoothly moving Blobs of
activity in our latent space if we're
modeling a pendulum we similarly get
kind of complex oscillatory activity
so it's preserved input structure but
additionally more flexibility than we
had before which is kind of our ultimate
goal
so finally I want to talk a bit about
how I think the outcome of This research
may not only improve artificial
intelligence but also how it helps us
understand why our measurements of the
brain look the way they do so to give a
brief example of what I mean by this uh
I talked a bit about before about visas
and places so in this fantastic work
with Ching higao we studied if our
simple topographic prior as we discussed
may be able to reproduce these same
effects so specifically we put the value
of this Cohen's D selectivity metric for
each of our neurons with respect to a
different data set of images potentially
containing just faces or just objects or
bodies
and so we measure for every neuron is it
more likely to respond to faces or the
Russian emerges in the brain but I do
think that it tells us that the relative
organization of selectivity May at least
be partially attributable to correlation
statistics in the data have to repath
after being passed through a highly
non-linear future extractor such as a
deep neural network
so in a similar vein something that's
interesting there's a known what's
called tripartite or not the visual
stream so uh images of uh or objects are
the selectivity with respect to objects
is organized by more abstract properties
such as animacy is this thing alive or
inanimate uh versus also real world
object size like what is the size of a
teapot versus a car
um and what we see is that in the in
humans this the selectivity is organized
in this tripartite structure you
typically have small objects that are in
between animates and inanimate objects
in terms of their selectivity and we see
the same thing kind of happens here so
these are measuring the selectivity of
the same set of neurons but with respect
to these differences of stimuli you see
that the small cluster is in between
animate and inanimate cluster and again
this happens for multiple different
initializations so this is something I
hope we can explore a bit further for
this community I think it's interesting
because it's
it's really a way of showing that we
built a structured World model and
potentially this world model is
beneficial for
better representing real world data in a
structured way and you get lower free
energy in that sense
so
um I think by developing these models
like like we showed here we may get
insights into new mechanisms for how
this structure emerges uh including
topographic organization that we never
thought of before so Machine model I was
looking at the orientation selectivity
uh of neurons which I wasn't
particularly expecting something to
happen but uh you're looking at kind of
these waves propagate over this
simulated vertical surface and I thought
okay maybe I'm showing rotated images
maybe this has some effect on the
orientation selectivity
and actually if you go in and you
measure the selectivity of each neuron
with respect to these differently
oriented lines what you see is that it's
surprisingly reminiscent of the Orient
type of columns that are seen in primary
visual cortex this is stuff going back
to Hugo and weasel and this is something
that just kind of came out of this model
and the fact that it has the spatial
temporal structure with respect to
Transformations so uh of course this is
a really coarse analogy but I think this
is an example of how building these
types of models can help us think about
how the brain builds representational
structure and the white the way it's
organized in a way that maybe we haven't
thought about before
um I I think I'm not the only one who's
doing this type of work and and so I
want to talk a little bit about some
other people who are doing this uh so
I've been talking about like this
equivalent structure
um people such as James Whittington and
Tim Barons and surrogengoolie uh have
shown recently that by introducing
algebraic constraints into uh into a
learning process in this case it was
like the motion of uh and and agents in
an environment by saying you need to
preserve kind of this algebraic
structure if I move in a Circle West
Northeast South I end up back at the
same point Again by introducing these
types of constraints
you get the emergence of grid cell like
representations
um so I'd be interested to see how this
idea of representational structure can
help us explain maybe more than our
scientific findings we're finding as
well
um and and how this relates to
generative models as a whole
um and then finally I think there's
something to be said about cognitive
possibility of these models as well
maybe we're not just going to be testing
them from uh neuroscience perspective
but also for micrognitive science
perspective for example there's these uh
Ravens Progressive matrices on the left
where you have to like say which one of
these images is more likely to fit in
this pattern
um or for example How likely is it that
this Jenga Tower Falls over when you
pull over a pull a specific block or or
with a given structure and I think these
things are
these types of tests are really testing
if our world models that we're building
are similar to the types of models that
we innately have our own common sense as
as humans or as beings living in a
natural world and I've done some
preliminary work in this direction I
think very uh preliminary and not nearly
this complicated but um kind of trying
to model visual Illusions so if you take
a really simple data set of a moving bar
stimuli or a static bar or frame and you
move it a little bit you can see that
the model will actually infer that
missing frame and then actually also
infer continued motion so it's like
overshooting the trajectory of what the
actual stimuli is providing it before
correcting again so I think modeling
Illusions is certainly an interesting
way to study if our world models are
similar to the types of models that we
have ourselves
so in conclusion uh yeah I think
topographic priors we could show that
they effectively learned structured
representations or structured World
models this learned structure is
flexible and adaptable to arbitrary
Transformations unlike traditional
equivariants and topographic providers
can be induced statistically as we did
in the topographic vae or through
Dynamics like we were showing in these
neural wave machine type models
so to conclude I'll leave you with this
quote that I found in fukushima's paper
from 1980 I thought was pretty far ahead
of its time where he says if we could
make a neural network model which has
the same capability for pattern
recognition as a human being it would
give us a powerful clue compared to
understanding the neural mechanism in
the brain so that's kind of I think some
of the goals that we're going for here
so I think it's my advisor Max my
co-authors Patrick UA Emil jinghian and
Yorn and interested in discussion thanks
all right
all right thank you great very uh
interesting presentation
a lot of places to start maybe just uh
what brought you to this work
a little context on how you came into
this work for your PhD Direction
yeah
um
I mean we've been studying not my the
group that I'm in at the university has
been studying structured representations
from uh mathematical point of view for a
while on where some of the people have
models uh are for like the variational
auto encoder
um and
I guess what something that had always
been
it's a model that respects rotations 2D
rotations perfectly well but if we want
to do 3D rotations we can't do that
because that's not a group in terms of a
projection onto a 2d plan there's you're
losing information when this thing
rotates around for example
um
or just any sort of natural
Transformations like I was trying to
point out at the beginning I think it
was
trying to think about how the brain
models natural Transformations is
something that this these current
Frameworks
where do you see action playing a role
in terms of variational autoencoder
models that include not just
external patterns but also the
consequences of action or World model
structural structure with action
right yeah no that's a good question and
I think acted inferences uh
is effectively the the answer I think
it's a good answer to that
um I know there are
reinforcement learning Frameworks that
do use
kind of externally trained World models
so you train a vae or something and then
you use that representation in in your
reinforcement learning system but I
think having a fully
kind of a system that is a single
objective with uh action as part of the
likelihood of the data and uh
yeah I think that's much more elegant
and and so I'm a big proponent of that
um
I have not gotten so far as to study how
these structured World models in a vae
or I haven't worked on that at all but I
think it would certainly be very
interesting to see if having a more
structured World model
uh in a variational auto encoder would
be beneficial in that in an active
setting as well I think that would be
awesome I mean I think
some of these examples like uh showing
before like emergence of grid cells and
things like this maybe points towards
that direction
okay maybe the brain is doing something
it's really obviously has a lot of
structure
um this clearly has to be useful for
performing actions in some way
oh yeah I felt a really
nice parallel that you brought in with
the talk was the locally connected units
enabled your models to structurally
embody the convolutional
constraint and pattern and that led to
these arising patterns and then
analogously there was the uh Doral at
all where they had the path exploration
constraint right and so then it's
interesting to to
um you know think about these action or
policy heuristics or sparsities like a
joint motor exploration eventually it
becomes understood that there's like two
mutually opposing ways to move a joint
and then the compositionality across
joints can can be learned at these
higher levels once it's locked in at
lower levels so it's a very appealing
and uh
uh Niche relevant way to generalize
because it's both based upon the actual
constraints of the world but then
especially through action
potentially embedding something that's
quite simple
right yeah no I think that's definitely
true that's a really good point if uh if
you do have constraints coming from your
actions themselves then that's that
would be hugely beneficial for helping
to structure your
your latent space and I think yeah I
guess one thing I wanted to mention
there's
um
something made me think of like Stefano
fousey's work on kind of the
representational geometry uh
determines how we how
how generalizable a given understanding
of a system is uh and I think if you can
understand like these uh sets of
activities are separable or highly
parallel separable with a linear
classifier essentially then you're going
to be able to do generalization and I
think by imposing these types of biases
or potentially through
constraints that are imposed by action
something like this
you are yielding or kind of inducing a
better representational geometry and
this has all sorts of benefits for like
compositionality
yeah our generalization so
it's a great Point cool yeah very
interesting area all right I'll read
some questions from the live chat
love evolve wrote
any practical or observed limitations on
modeling illusions
learning communities is they're not
phobiated you don't have a a center of
gaze then you also don't have
um
like a time I mean most convolutional
neural networks I'm using these kind of
recurrent neural networks but time is
not as clearly defined in these models
as it is in a continuous time setting
for for a human undergoing an illusion
trial
um
and I think the combination of these two
of the fact that as a human or most
things uh
your gaze your shifting locations and
your gains are dependent on like you
looking to a particular area a lot of
cognitive tests and so I think it would
be really helpful if we had models that
yeah I mean learn that you can think of
this as a type of action like learning
where to move your gaze one of the
simplest possible that would help a lot
for being able to model Illusions and
just I mean for me it's like I read a
paper of some cognitive science
experiments or about some illusion and
it's like I think of okay can I put this
data set into my model and test it and
most of the time the answer is no
because I don't have a model that
looks around or has a restricted field
of view something like that
so yeah I think that's one of the
limitations another one is
um
yeah make the experiment much more
complicated so that's one of the
Practical limitations
wow great answer makes me think of a
paper with letters rotating on a table
that's the digit rotation great points
about the foveation and the Dynamics of
the illusion I think you actually did
mention an illusion which is however you
mentioned in the generalization context
which is rotating on the two-dimensional
screen doesn't generalize to three
dimensions and that dimensional collapse
or reduction is the basis of the cube
projection Illusions and Cube and figure
rotation Illusions it's on your screen
and there's a silhouette or there's some
ambiguous
stimuli that a generative it's near
criticality or a bifurcation in
degenerative models so it could
represent it one way or another way
and so a lot of the switching Illusions
are just based upon the flatness of
images
and the limitations and generalization
that are revealed by that
right yeah yeah I think there's even Oh
Yes somewhere sorry there's some work or
they
can argue people have a
three-dimensional image in their heads
like even Nancy Ken was a or her
laterals recently but and showing yeah I
don't know do do our models have that
it's not super big
anyway yeah that's pretty interesting
um all right from upcycle Club in the
chat they wrote kudos
if you're able to learn nearly as
effectively if you imagine you only want
a single neuron to be active for every
example uh your model is going to be
trying to memorize the data set design
or something like this
um and you're not going to have enough
capacity so yeah I think tuning that
level of sparsity is certainly uh
an important factor and
yeah when you look at the likelihood if
you're talking if you're doubling
framework typically this is balanced
automatically with the likelihood itself
um
if you're not doing generate modeling
you just have a sparsity penalty you're
going to want to tune in that parameter
okay yeah it's just just to clarify
runaway behavior in armina where the
network becomes unstable or chaotic due
to various factors such as feedback
loops noise or adversarial inputs
um
yeah I guess I haven't looked at this in
in like a recurrent setting where you
would get feedback loops
um
but I could yeah I could see adversarial
examples being potentially
affected by your level of sparsity
um
the interesting point is what would you
be more susceptible or less susceptible
to share examples I don't know
well sparsification
projecting from a fully connected higher
dimensional model just into
progressively smaller
it's pretty well understood in general
what the trade-offs are it's easier
computations a smaller model sparser
the basic graph is going to be clearer
to represent and then also it will have
all of the other trade-offs with false
positive and negatives of generalizing
but that's why it's an iterative fit
process so
I guess how does your
sparsification approach
balance
doesn't use AIC or Bic or some other
model fitting approach to determine the
relevant sparsification
for a given input
how do you determine how like like in
lasso regression like how do you know
how how much how do you threshold how
many how sparse you want it to be
right yeah I think there's a lot of good
literature on this and even so some
people like them at Harvard and some
people are working with now uh have done
these
that kind of unrolled
um iterative sparsification networks
where it's like a recurrent neural
network and iteratively sparsifies and
you can show that this yields something
like red lose or uh group like group
active group Sports activations like
we're using here
um in this setting uh it's really just
by having this
um this construction of this T variable
where we have Z on top and uh
and then it's in some effect gated by
these
the sum of U variables in the bottom so
if W maybe I wasn't super clear about
this is a matrix that is connecting
that's what defines the group so I'm
defining the group's Varsity uh that
connects all these U's together and so
the idea is
uh like here if all of one of the other
examples if all of your use uh are not
active for a given t
or if all varios are active for a given
t uh that t variable is going to be very
small right because your denominator is
going to be very big and that induces
sparsity so it's uh it's a constraint
satisfaction if you have a if you have a
set of U's that are all small uh then
that that constraint is satisfied and
now Z is allowed to kind of Express
itself and that's what then
uh kind of yeah achieves as far as
Activation so this is induced by these
two
uh kale Divergence terms here these are
saying like how far is the each unhc
from a gaussian and then through this
construction of the student T variable
we're effectively constructing a sparse
prior distribution just from these
gaussians but in terms of the act the
actual objective uh the terms and the
objective that we're optimizing are just
these two KL terms that are pushing it
towards sparsity to some extent and this
is balanced automatically with the
likelihood term here through the decoder
so we don't have terms that we're tuning
but we're learning the parameters of
these different encoders and then
analyzing the failed and emergencies
oh
all right another question from Dave
Douglas who wrote
speaking of gaze and illusion can the
studies on constances in infants be
separated into lower level illusion Rel
perhaps higher level
conceptual constancy
uh can you read
the current kind of architecture might
the studies on constances in in infants
um cognitive constances be separated
yeah probably I'm not I'm not uh
an expert or actually even very familiar
with like
object permanency studies and infants
and constancy stuff so but I think that
would be incredibly interesting to study
in in neural network architectures and
that was kind of some of the idea with
this uh illusion that I was trying to
model down here with this line I don't
know if I was super clear about this but
the top row is the input and we're
effectively like blocking the input for
a single frame and I wanted to see does
the network kind of encode that that the
thing is still there when that frame is
gone can I still decode the presence of
the object from the neural activity uh
and then what is it also inferring about
the motion because of the fact that it
saw the bars at a slightly different
location than from before when the after
the frame is gone
um so
yeah I think it's definitely multiple
levels to it
um where some would probably be much
lower level and uh
maybe long-term object permanency I
would guess would be significantly
higher level
um
it just makes me think of those
experiments with cats back in the day
where it's like they raise them in
darkness except for an hour a day they
put them in Vertical World or horizontal
world or they only saw horizontal lines
or vertical lines uh and you can see the
the organization of their cortex changes
like they have less receptivity it's a
horizontal lines if they've never seen
horizontal lines before and then you
take a stick and you wave it in front of
their face and if the stick is
horizontal they just they do nothing
it's vertical they're swatting at it
they're trying to hit it it's like they
just literally don't have to Bar in
front of their face so I think in that
case then this is evidence of a
low-level deficiency and vision
contributing to some sort of an illusion
so I I think yeah there could certainly
be some aspect of that in infants as
well
one very curious point you've brought up
was the animate and inanimate
manifold with small things being
intermediate
right what does that represent
or or is it because they're handleable
or it might be an insect or it might be
something that might move away just with
wind or what does that say
right yeah uh
so this is work by like Talia conkle I
think was the one who discovered this
um
organization and they they tried to
figure it out I don't I might be getting
this wrong so I recommend people to read
her work on that if they call it
tripartite organization but if I
remember correctly
they did a lot of follow-up work on why
it's there's this organization and
some evidence of
curvature of these objects and kind of
like the distance that you see objects
from or like
um animate objects or maybe more curvy
or there's there regardless of what the
actual answer is there were a lot of
different hypotheses that were stemming
from like properties of these objects
maybe mid-level or low level properties
more so than higher level properties I
still don't know if it's exactly been
solved of whether it's like
interaction like you said with the
objects causes the separation or
um
or yeah the general shapes of these
objects I would bet as with most things
it's like some combination of all of the
above uh but I think the interesting
thing from this modeling point of view
is that
um
this is only trained on correlation
statistics from the image data sets
itself so this has no interaction this
has no notion of animacy uh I mean this
is really just training a model on
imagenet just images of dogs cats boats
whatever and yet it still achieves this
type of organization so there's some
sort of
it could be semantic characteristics
right we have image we have a network
that can classify
boats versus dogs versus 20 other breeds
of dogs but if
it might also have some correspondence
with lower level finish statistics as
well
so yeah I don't know I guess
yeah provocative analogy was the
translational shift
in the mnist in the handwriting
recognition setting
what are the translational shifts
that
exists today what's the three pixel
example is that some prompt engineered
attack on an llm or something or
something right a special character
being inserted or or a um uh some
overlay on an image that we can't even
detect that
so what do you think those challenges
are and what are ways that we can pursue
that
yeah absolutely I mean I think it's kind
of
the way I was thinking about it is like
these symmetry Transformations
um
if you're thinking about language models
you can imagine a symmetry
transformation that's just like
replacing a word with a synonym or
something uh you have the sentence to us
means the exact same thing but now
suddenly the model is going to respond
very differently
um
like translation between languages this
can be seen as a type of transformation
it preserves the underlying
meaning of the input
to us but to the model it looks
completely different and we would like
to have models which behave in a
predictable way with respect to these
types of Transformations because
I think humans behave very predictably
since these Transformations and when
we're dealing with AI systems we expect
them to also behave that way and I think
that's part of what causes a lot of
challenges interacting with these
systems and I kind of tried to do a
rough cheeky demonstration of that with
with this bear and squares and stuff
like um we expect
it to be able to do something simple
like this because we think most humans
could and yet it doesn't and if you
imagine this is a critical scenario
where you expect this and that's a big
problem
um how do we handle that that's yeah I
think that's kind of the what I'm
searching for I think
my
Direction I'm taking it is look
more simple and like bottom up
building blocks of
neural network architectures or
algorithms that
kind of yield these emergent structural
properties and I think that's a much
more generalizable way rather than
building something on top of what we
already have
um
I think that's something that will scale
much better and also matches more what
the brain does
very cool one kind of implementational
question what are the computational
requirements of just running this or
what's the day-to-day like of being a
student or researcher running variants
of these like do they use terabytes of
data and you're using large computation
or is this something that people can run
on their own laptops
I think almost everything I presented
today can be run locally so like
this stuff is super simple you can run I
mean
you're gonna you
think you can run it on your laptop if
you want to like train and experiment
with different things it's going to be
pretty slow so I'd recommend some
commercial GPU like a I run pretty much
everything on like Nvidia 1080s
pretty old pretty cheap but they have 12
gigs of RAM or whatever and it's kind of
more than enough for these models four
gigabytes of RAM I think one thing that
some people think is weird is I do most
of my experiments on stuff like mnist so
it's 32 by 32 pixel images because I can
train it small and vocally
um if you want to do so my experiments
or an endless if you want to do stuff
like this these are much more
complicated this hamiltonian Dynamic
Suite here you're getting into bigger
models that are running across multiple
gpus and so here is using a cluster to
run these types of models
um but I'd say most of the single
machine with the GPU is more than enough
or even just like in a collab notebook
something like that if you want to train
something on imagenet it gets more
complicated and you need
at least one GPU ideally more but yeah I
don't do a whole lot of big scale stuff
yet I think it's certainly interesting
and there's definitely a lot more you
can do there but for some of these kind
of simpler or more fundamental questions
I don't know what you want to call it um
a smaller machine is nice and fast so
cool useful
all right I'll read a comment from Dave
recalling Bert DeVries comment during
the applied active inference Symposium
about the desirability of spending less
effort or ATP on foraging or control
situations where we don't need much
Precision I don't know if you listen to
this but Professor DeVries mentioned
about variable Precision models and how
they could be used to
enable different features of
generalization and actual structural
course training as well as like reduced
computational requirements
does he have any suggestions on how to
introduce this distinction into active
inference Theory what kinds of
experiments could Winkle this out
oh wow yeah that's something I don't I
don't think I have too much intelligent
to say about that's completely honest
um
it's super interesting question because
I think the intuition makes a lot of
sense to me that uh
you're talking about
if I understand correctly variable rates
of precision when you're encoding in or
or in your model in general doing
computation
[Music]
um
that somehow has an impact on your your
future performance as a relation to some
energy store I think yeah and if you
wanted to build this into an active
effort system you would need to have
really an embodied system where the
agent has some notion of energy like an
internal energy store and
yeah something something that is trying
to conserve while it's performing its
actions uh
and running out of energy would need to
need something bad for the agents and
then maybe you could observe kind of an
emergence
uh reduction and
encoding Precision or something like
this as as the agent is trying to learn
to act more effectively you might have
to give it an ability to control its
precision
yeah like I say out of my expertise but
it's kind of thoughts
okay on this slide right here first very
cool image it's kind of like a
digital Jackson Pollock
um if it were a simpler input data
size or just reduced complexity of
patterns or if it were an increased
complexity how would this image look
different
yeah so I did some experiments trying to
change these
orientation columns and
um
you can yeah basically changing the
parameters of the model you can get
these columns to be bigger you can get
them to not have very similar structure
to what we see in the humans where we
have you you can get them to have more
bands of activity
um
and it also like you said it depends on
the data set that you're using if I use
like really simple sinusoidal gradings
as input I get something like this I get
something that's a little bit more uh
rotational curvy higher entropy
um
so I think these are all interesting
things if you want to study the
emergence of this type of organization
in a natural system uh if you have a
model that now yields different
Organization for different
settings that's a see okay then what
settings best match our observed data
um
so so yeah I can
I can send those around it if you're
interested but
um
yeah I think one also other sorry one
one other interesting point there is
that the
uh different animals and types of uh
orientation selectivity and different
numbers of pinwheels some animals don't
have it at all I think maybe mice if I'm
correct have this kind of uh they call a
salt and pepper selectivity so it's
basically random you don't have any sort
of like topographic orientation
sensitivity
um so there is evidence that
yeah different systems do this
differently and it's interesting to
figure out why
yeah this is very cool it reminds me of
first the reaction diffusion
base and time
so it's actually
um possible that a region might have no
activity from a given
granularity like if it was being looked
at at fmri spatial and temporal time
scale
if the pockets of activity but if the
pockets of activity are
slower faster
than that measurement is going to not be
different than noise it'll all have been
averaged out
so then there might be some yeah
interesting like data sets that do
actually have a lot of
richness but then for one reason or
another it just was averaged out over
because it wasn't being connected to you
or something like this you really need
to go with a single trial level you need
to have high enough spatial resolution
such that it's you know it satisfies
micro frequencies uh and and this just
is something that people didn't do for a
long time especially if you're doing
single electorate recordings you're not
going to see a traveling wave you're
going to see oscillations
um so you need like multi-electric
arrays and basically they're saying okay
yeah now that we have the technology to
do this as much
persists that we didn't see before and
potentially this is an explanation for a
lot of the noise that we were seeing
before maybe it really is just traveling
waves
um
so yeah I think there's a lot to be done
in the future with increased
abilities for recording
that's very cool
well any final thoughts or questions or
where are you gonna take this work
yeah no thanks for having me
um
hopefully in the active infrastructure
that's that's I would love to I think
that would be super fun so yeah I'm not
really sure I'm looking at Maybe music
uh right now
um
looking at uh
other other crazy directions I don't
want to sound too crazy uh
but I'll go down yeah a lot of things so
one one thing that's coming up something
we submitted to neurops is studying
memory with traveling waves
um so that paper just came out on
archive today uh
how waves are really good at encoding
long-term memories which I think is
super interesting
so I might go a little one in that
direction
sounds good and yes would be very
exciting to see action come into play
when there was the neurons that stayed
active even as the dog's feet were
moving
there's a lot of like action sequences
like throwing a baseball and then it
goes and it's like there's something
about that action that's continuing to
influence and so having like a deep
temporal representation of alternative
actions
and then the variational autoencoder is
already basically the right anything
like that so
really appreciate it all right thank you
until next time
thanks so much bye